Війна у серці Європи…
Пандемія коронавірусу…
…та ядерні погрози з боку Росії примушують багатьох людей замислитися про пошук надійного прихистку,
зокрема - в приватному бункері!
Після повномасштабного вторгнення РФ в Україну бізнес зі спорудження таких підземних квартир процвітає.
Зокрема ці харківські підприємці зайнялися виготовленням повністю автономних бункерних квартир,
здатних витримувати прямі влучання важкої артилерії.
Ідея створення такого сховища з'явилася ще влітку, коли я був змушений розлучитися з сім'єю.
Я мав працювати у Харкові, бо тут знаходиться наше виробництво. А моя сім'я, на жаль, не могла повернутися,
бо вони боялися. Тоді в Харкові ще була така складна ситуація з артобстрілами та обстрілами ракетами С-300.
Тож я подумав: що мені треба зробити, щоб моя сім'я була зі мною? Тому ми вирішили робити такі сховища.
Бункерні квартири made in Ukraine повністю автономні.
На площі 17 квадратних метрів уміщується весь набір зручностей, включно з кухнею, ванною і туалетом.
Спальня, розрахована на трьох осіб, тобто три комфортних ліжка, розташована в дальній частині сховища.
Потім у нас кухня. Власне, ми зараз знаходимося у кухні. Тут у нас буде плита. Тут буде стіл.
Сусіднє приміщення - санвузол з душовою кабіною.
Запасів води, їжі, електрики та опалення має вистачити на тиждень повністю автономного проживання сім'ї з трьох осіб.
Водопостачання, каналізація, вентиляція, опалення та струм розташовані під підлогою. Плюс є ще один бонус.
Схов має броньовані двері із спеціальним замком.
Тобто у разі окупації чи облоги двері такі міцні, що їх треба буде підривати вибухівкою. Інакше проникнути сюди окупанти не зможуть.
Виготовлення одного такого укриття триває близько 2 місяців.
Після цього бункер закопують у землю та укріплюють бетоном.
Розробники стверджують, що таке укриття здатне витримувати прямі влучання артилерії калібру 152 мм.
Таке спорудження може захистити від прямих попадань важкої артилерії калібром 152 мм, яку часто використовують у цій війні.
Якщо його занурити глибше і відлити товстішу залізобетонну плиту, то він може захистити і від більших ракет більшого калібру.
Розробники вже отримали кілька запитів. Вартість такої квартири-бункера становить близько 60 тисяч доларів.
Якщо порівняти з цінами на нерухомість у Харкові до 24 лютого, це приблизно вартість 2-кімнатної квартири.
А тепер перемістімося до Польщі. Це сімейне підприємство у Свідвині раніше виробляло автозапчастини.
А віднедавна переорієнтувалося на будівництво бункерів.
Працівники саме виготовляють двері, які вестимуть до підземного сховища.
Робітник саме приварює люк до електрогенератора з куленепробивної сталі.
Він має шість додаткових засувів, які замикаються зсередини. Ніхто не зможе потрапити всередину.
А ось так двері зачиняються зсередини.
Можна заховатися усією сім'єю. Не потрібно нічого зварювати. Вантажівка приїжджає.
Бункер знімають. Опускають у цемент, і він розташовується на глибині півтора метра під землею.
Бункер ховають під землею в саду покупця. У ньому є дизельний генератор для екстреного забезпечення струмом.
А також система очищення повітря. Прокручування лебідки упродовж 20 хвилин щогодини
забезпечує свіже повітря в бункері навіть за відсутності струму.
Якщо на вулиці випали радіоактивні опади, вона фільтрує всі часточки гамма-випромінювання через цей фільтр, і система працює таким чином.
Вона подає свіже повітря в бункер. Якщо вимикається електрика, є ось такий ручний вимикач.
Цей розкішний бункер може прихистити вісім осіб. У ньому є спальня, ванна кімната, кухня й вітальня.
Його вартість - 600 тисяч євро. Але є також варіанти менших розмірів від 350 тисяч.
Але що спонукає клієнтів замовляти такі бункери?
Два роки тому ми мали Covid. Зараз у нас війна, і ніхто не міг собі уявити, що війна буде в Європі.
Є й інші конфлікти - між Китаєм і Тайванем або між Індією і Пакистаном.
ЗМІ попереджають нас про продовольчу кризу та нестачу води. Ніхто не знає, що ще трапиться.
Якщо хочете відчувати себе в безпеці, ми запропонуємо рішення.
Клієнтами польської фірми є насамперед американці та німці.
Приміром, берлінська компанія BSSD, яка також виготовляє бункери. З початком війни в Україні показники продажів різко зросли.
Так, ми також побачили це за кількістю відвідувань нашого сайту. Раніше у нас було близько 100 відвідувань на день,
а потім раптом стало 10 000 відвідувань на день.
Можна лише собі уявити, який це потенціал. І ми, звісно, замислюємося: так, війна триває відносно довго,
але в якийсь момент вона закінчиться, то чи зникне цей попит. Але поки ми цього не спостерігаємо.
Фірма пропонує бункери різних розмірів. Навіть маленьку "тривожну кімнату" за 15 000 євро.
Наразі робітники виготовляють кілька бункерів одночасно.
Замовлення надходять від заможних людей з усієї Європи, які хочуть закопати бункер біля або під своїм будинком.